[Music]
so i have bad news i have good news and
i have a task
so the bad news is that we all get sick
i get sick you get sick
every one of us gets sick and the
question really is how sick do we get is
it something that kills us is it
something that we survive is it
something that we can treat
and we've gotten sick as long as we've
been people and so we've always looked
for reasons to explain why we get sick
and for a long time it was the gods
right the gods are angry with me or the
gods are testing me
right or god singular more recently
is punishing me or judging me
and as long as you've looked for
explanations
we've wound up with something that gets
closer and closer to science which is
hypotheses as to why we get sick
and as long as we've had hypotheses
about why we get sick we've tried to
treat it as well
this is avasena he wrote a book over a
thousand years ago called the canon of
medicine
and the rules he laid out for testing
medicines are actually really similar to
the rules we have today that the disease
and the medicine must be the same
strength the medicine needs to be pure
and in the end we need to test it in
people
and so if you put together these themes
of a narrative or a hypothesis
in human testing
right you get some beautiful results
even we didn't have very good
technologies this is a guy named carlos
finlay he had a hypothesis that was way
outside the box for his time in the late
1800s he thought yellow fever was not
transmitted by dirty clothing he thought
it was transmitted by mosquitoes
and they laughed at him for 20 years
they called this guy the mosquito man
but he ran an experiment in people right
he had his hypothesis and he tested in
people so he got volunteers to go move
to cuba and live in tents and be
voluntarily infected with yellow fever
so some of the people in some of the
tents had dirty clothes and some of the
people were in tents that were full of
mosquitoes that had been exposed to
yellow fever
and it definitively proved that it
wasn't this magic dust called fomites in
your clothes that caused yellow fever
right but it wasn't until we tested it
in people that we actually knew
and this is what those people signed up
for this is what it looked like to have
yellow fever in cuba at that time you
suffered in a tent in the heat
alone and you probably died
but people volunteered for this
and it's not just a cool example of a
scientific design of experiment in
theory they also did this beautiful
thing they signed this document and it's
called an informed consent document
and informed consent is an idea that we
should be very proud of as a society
right it's something that separates us
from the nazis at nuremberg enforced
medical experimentation it's the idea
that agreement to join a study without
understanding isn't agreement
it's something that protects us
from harm from hucksters from people
that would try to hoodwink us
into a clinical study that we don't
understand or that we don't agree to
and so you put together the thread
of narrative hypothesis experimentation
and human uninformed consent and you get
what we call clinical study and it's how
we do the vast majority of medical work
it doesn't really matter here in the
north to south the east the west
clinical studies
form the basis of how we investigate so
if we're going to look at a new drug
right we test it in people we draw blood
we do experiments and we gain consent
for that study to make sure that we're
not screwing people over as part of it
but the world is changing around the
clinical study which has been fairly
well established for tens of years if
not 50 to 100 years
so now we were able to gather data about
our genomes but as we saw earlier our
genomes aren't dispositive
we're able to gather information about
our environment
and more importantly we're able to
gather information about our choices
because it turns out that what we think
of as our health is more like the
interaction of our bodies our genomes
our choices and our environment
and the clinical methods that we've got
aren't very good at studying that
because they are based on the idea of
person-to-person interaction you
interact with your doctor and you get
enrolled in the study so this is my
grandfather i actually never met him
but he's holding my mom and his genes
are in me right
his choices ran through to me he was a
smoker like most people this is my son
so my grandfather's jeans go all the way
through to him
and my choices are going to affect his
health
the technology between these two
pictures
cannot be more different
but the methodology for clinical studies
has not radically changed over that time
period we just have better statistics
the way we gain informed consent
was formed in large part after world war
ii around the time that picture was
taken that was 70 years ago
and the way we gain informed consent
this tool that is created to protect us
from harm now creates silos so the data
that we collect for prostate cancer or
for alzheimer's trials goes into silos
where it can only be used for prostate
cancer or for alzheimer's research
right it can't be networked it can't be
integrated it cannot be used by people
who aren't credentialed so a physicist
can't get access to it without filing
paperwork a computer scientist can't get
access to it without filing paperwork
computer scientists aren't patient
they don't file paperwork
[Applause]
this is an accident
these are tools that we created to
protect us from harm
what they're doing is protecting us from
innovation now
and that wasn't the goal it wasn't the
point
right it's a side effect if you will of
a power we created to take us for good
and so if you think about it the
depressing thing is that facebook would
never make a change to something as
important as an advertising algorithm
with a sample size as small as a phase
three clinical trial
we cannot take the information from past
trials and put them together to form
statistically significant samples
and that sucks right so 45 of men
develop cancer
38 of women develop cancer one in four
men dies of cancer
one in five women dies of cancer at
least in the united states
and three out of the four drugs we give
you if you get cancer fail and this is
personal to me my sister is a cancer
survivor my mother-in-law is a cancer
survivor cancer sucks
and when you have it you don't have a
lot of privacy in the hospital you're
naked the vast majority of the time
people you don't know come in and look
at you and poke you and prod you
and when i tell cancer survivors that
this tool we created to protect them is
actually preventing their data from
being used
especially when only three to four
percent of people who have cancer ever
even sign up for a clinical study their
reaction is not thank you god for
protecting my privacy
it's outrage
that we have this information and we
can't use it and it's an accident
so the cost and blood and treasure of
this is enormous
226 billion a year is spent on cancer in
the united states 1500 people a day die
in the united states
and it's getting worse
so the good news is that some things
have changed and the most important
thing that's changed is that we can now
measure ourselves in ways that used to
be the dominion of the health system so
a lot of people talk about it as digital
exhaust i like to think of it as the
dust that runs along behind my kid
we can reach back and grab that dust and
we can learn a lot about health from it
so if our choices are part of our health
what we eat is a really important aspect
of our health so you can do something
very simple and basic and take a picture
of your food and enough people do that
we can learn a lot about how our food
affects our health
one interesting thing that came out of
this this is an app
for iphones called the eatery is that we
think our pizza is significantly
healthier than other people's pizza is
and it seems like a trivial result but
this is the sort of research that used
to take the health system
years and hundreds of thousands of
dollars to accomplish it was done in
five months by a startup company of a
couple of people i don't have any
financial interest in it
but more non-trivially we can get our
genotypes done and although our
genotypes aren't just positive they give
us clues so i could show you mine it's
just a's t's c's and g's this is the
interpretation of it as you can see i
carry a 32 risk of prostate cancer 22
risk of psoriasis and a 14 risk of
alzheimer's disease
so that means if you're a geneticist
you're freaking out going oh my god
you're told everyone you carry the apoe4
allele what's wrong with you
right when i got these results i started
talking to doctors and they told me not
to tell anyone in my reaction is that
going to help anyone cure me when i get
the disease
and no one can tell me yes
and i live in a web world where when you
share things beautiful stuff happens not
bad stuff so i started putting this in
my slide decks and i got even more
obnoxious and i went to my doctor i said
i'd like to get my blood work
please give me back my data so this is
my most recent blood work as you can see
i have high cholesterol
i have particularly high bad cholesterol
and i have some bad liver numbers but
those are because we had a dinner party
with a lot of good wine the night before
we ran the test
but look at how non-computable this
information is this is like the
photograph of my granddad holding my mom
from a data perspective and i had to go
into the system and get it out
so the thing that i'm proposing we do
here is that we reach behind us and we
grab the dust
that we reach into our bodies and we
grab the genotype and we reach into the
medical system when we grab our records
and we use it to build something
together which is a commons
and there's been a lot of talk about
commons's right here there everywhere
right a commons is nothing more than a
public good that we build out of private
goods
we do it voluntarily we do it through
standardized legal tools we do it
through standardized technologies
that's all a commons is it's something
that we build together because we think
it's important
and a commons of data is something
that's really unique because we make it
from our own data
and although a lot of people like
privacy as their methodology of control
around data and obsess around privacy at
least some of us really like to share as
a form of control
and what's remarkable about digital
commons is is you don't need a big
percentage
if your sample size is big enough to
generate something massive and beautiful
so not that many programmers write free
software but we have the apache web
server
not that many people who read wikipedia
edit but it works
so as long as some people like to share
as their form of control we can build a
commons as long as we can get the
information out
and in biology the numbers are even
better so vanderbilt ran a study asking
people we'd like to take your bio
samples your blood and share them in a
bio bank and only five percent of the
people opted out
i'm from tennessee it's not the most
science positive state in the united
states of america
but only five percent of people want it
out
so people like to share if you give them
the opportunity and the choice
and the reason that i got obsessed with
this besides the obvious family aspects
is that i spend a lot of time around
mathematicians
and mathematicians are drawn to places
where there's a lot of data because they
can use it to tease signals out of noise
and those correlations they can tease
out they're not necessarily causal
agents
but math in this day and age is like a
giant set of power tools
that we're leaving on the floor
not plugged in in health while we use
hand saws
if we have
a lot of shared genotypes and a lot of
shared outcomes and a lot of shared
lifestyle choices and a lot of shared
environmental information
we can start to tease out the
correlations between subtle variations
in people
the choices they make and the health
that they create as a result of those
choices and there's open source
infrastructure to do all of this sage
bionetworks is a non-profit that's built
a giant math system that's waiting for
data
but there isn't
any so that's what i do i've actually
started what we think is the world's
first fully digital
fully self-contributed
unlimited in scope
global and participation ethically
approved clinical research study where
you contribute the data
so if you reach behind yourself and you
grab the dust if you reach into your
body and grab your genome if you reach
into the medical system and somehow
extract your medical record
you can actually go through an online
informed consent process because the
donation to the commons must be
voluntary and it must be informed
and you can actually upload your
information and have it syndicated to
the mathematicians who will do this sort
of big data research
and the goal is to get a hundred
thousand in the first year and a million
in the first five years so that we have
a statistically significant cohort that
you can use to take smaller sample sizes
from traditional research and map it
against
since you can use it to tease out those
subtle correlations between the
variations that make us unique
and the kinds of health that we need to
to move forward as a society
and i've spent a lot of time around
other comments i've been around the
early web i've been around the early
creative commons world and there's four
things that all of these share which is
they're all really simple and so if you
were to go to the website and enroll in
this study you're not going to see
something complicated
but it's not simplistic
these things are weak
intentionally right because you can
always add power and control to a system
but it's very difficult to remove those
things if you put them in at the
beginning
and so being simple doesn't mean being
simplistic and being weak doesn't mean
weakness
those are strengths in the system
and open doesn't mean that there's no
money
closed systems corporations make a lot
of money on the open web and they're one
of the reasons why the open web lives is
that corporations have a vested interest
in the openness of the system
so all of these things are part of this
of the clinical study that we've created
so you can actually come in all you have
to be is 14 years old willing to sign a
contract that says i'm not going to be a
jerk basically
and you're in you can start analyzing
the data you do have to solve a captcha
as well
right
and if you'd like to build corporate
structures on top of it that's okay too
that's all in the consent so if you
don't like those terms you don't come in
and it's very much the design principles
of a commons that we're trying to bring
to health data
and the other thing about these systems
is that it only takes a small number of
really unreasonable people working
together
to create
it didn't take that many people to make
wikipedia wikipedia or to keep it
wikipedia
and we're not supposed to be
unreasonable in health and so i hate
this word patient
right i don't like being patient when
systems are broken
and healthcare is broken
i'm talking about the politics of
healthcare i'm talking about the way we
scientifically approach healthcare so i
don't want to be patient and the task
i'm giving to you is to not be patient
so i'd like you to actually try when you
go home to get your data you'll be
shocked and offended and i would bet
outraged at how hard it is
to get it
but it's a challenge that i hope you'll
take
and maybe you'll share it maybe you
won't if you don't have anyone in your
family who's sick maybe you wouldn't be
unreasonable
but if you do if you've been sick then
maybe you would
and we're going to be able to do an
experiment in the next several months
that lets us know exactly how many
unreasonable people are out there this
is the athena breast health network it's
a study of 150 000 women in california
and they're going to return all the data
to the participants of the study in a
computable form with one click ability
to load it into the study that i've put
together so we'll know exactly how many
people are willing to be unreasonable
so what i'd end is
the most beautiful thing i've learned
since i quit my job almost a year ago to
do this
is that it really doesn't take very many
of us to achieve spectacular results
you just have to be willing to be
unreasonable and the risk we're running
is not the risk those 14 men who got
yellow fever ran right it's to be naked
digitally in public so you know more
about me and my health than i know about
you it's asymmetric now
and being naked and alone can be
terrifying
but to be naked in a group voluntarily
can be quite beautiful
and so it doesn't take all of us
it just takes all of some of us thank
you
[Music]